за
обрієм тихо перед нині перший день
вступної кампанії у вишах в
університетах озброєння як і торік
документи можна подавати до п'яти
університетів але на різні спеціальності
причому навіть не виходячи з дому
половина заявок зроблено через інтернет
з минулих років залишилася незмінною
квота для пільговиків 25 відсотків місць
просту по-українськи Христина
вступна кампанія у вищі навчальні
заклади цього розпочалася доволі
спокійно перший день прийому документів
підвищеними черг немає
Сергій прийшов випробувати Фортуну до
Національного університету Шевченка буде
документи одразу на три спеціальності за
дві з половиною години хлопець каже не
вірю власне щастя думав доведеться
стояти в черзі щонайменше до був я
взагалі очікував ще народу
як на концерті в
А кажуть комісії національного
університету перед вищим була невелика
черга яким вона скоро розсмокталася
чекали з батьками Вони чекали але вони
потім приходять зв'язки заповнюють заяви
її впринципі за рахунок цього черг немає
тому що робота оперативний де найбільший
ажіотаж Рятуйте Шевченка традиційно на
юридичний економічний факультет
міжнародні відносини та журналістику на
те щоб зареєструвати абітурієнта йде
Близько 10 хвилин принципі людей досить
багато навіть більше ніж минулого року
було середньому Ми витрачаємо 10 хвилин
80 на одну людину а от батьків так
Арифметика приймальної комісії не тішить
кажуть це неправда ми вже 3 години вже
надоїли сидіти висоти години дитина пише
що вони там роблять а це вже приймальна
комісія києво-могилянської академії Утім
картина не змінилась батьки знимають під
палючим сонцем діти здають документи
впринципі швидко без черги проблем немає
приймальна комісія радіє кажуть самі
у перший день буде настільки вдалим тому
бояться наврочити зізнаються поки що до
них не надійшло жодної скарги Я
очікувала більшу кількість абітурієнтів
очевидно спрацювало інформація про те що
в місяць триває Ця компанія вступна і не
має значення який день подаєте документи
має значення бали які з яким ви прийдете
у міносвіти мають власну версію Чому
перший день вступної кампанії настільки
спокійний це так званий електронний
вступ майбутній студент може просто з
дому надіслати заявку до будь-якого
університету України через інтернет у
міністерстві переконують це Набагато
зручніше і зекономить чималий часу
найбільший
інтерес на сьогодні являється так званий
електронний вступ
який дозволяє максимально зменшити
кількість людей які здають точно
заявою його ходою
12400 3 у
і електронні заяви
6292 А ще головні освітяни закликають
абітурієнтів та батьків бути пильними
ретельно придивлятися до університету
який хочуть обрати адже цьогоріч деяким
із них частково анулювала ліцензії до
чорного списку потрапили Львівський
інститут менеджменту Київський
славістичний університет та Київський
економічний інститут менеджменту
останній навіть прийоми навчання учнів
шкіл або подачі заміж частину складали
одразу 12 дисциплін тепер усіх тамтешні
студентів переведуть в інші університети
ліцензії яких анульовано
переведення їх на навчальних до інших
вищих навчальних закладів нового
навчання не гірших ніщо не було в тих
навчальних закладах таких вони навчалися
і
до кожного окремого студента займається
персонажем і Стежте аби не потрапити у
пастку для абітурієнтів Міністерства
відкрила г з будь-яких питань тож
Бажаємо вам успішного вступу
Ушинський Новий канал в